les bruits de bottes se font entendre
aux portes de l'europe mais bruxelles
peine à imposer sa voix union européenne
tente pourtant de raisonner la russie
sur le dossier ukrainien la présidente
de la commission appelle moscou à la
désescalade et à s'abstenir de toute
agression we should nous avons assuré à
l'ukraine notre soutien plein et entier
ainsi que notre engagement à sa
souveraineté et son intégrité
territoriale
un tel choc il ne doit y avoir aucun
doute sur le fait que l'union européenne
répondra fermement à toute nouvelle
agression contre luke schenn a gan
studio créé certaines sanctions existent
déjà mais ne font pas sourciller le
kremlin et kiev semble s'agacer du
manque d'engagement des 27
nous avons pu expliquer à nos collègues
européens que pour être honnête personne
n'est particulièrement intéressé par la
politique de sanction a posteriori
si notre état est intéressé par une
politique de cette chambre puissante
avant une éventuelle escalade d'eau et
ensuite il me semble qu'il n'y aura
peut-être pas des scans a aussi croisé
mon gendre ou un ministre européen cité
par la fp reconnu au micro que l'union
européenne ne représente rien pour
vladimir poutine et que le président
russe ne veut traiter qu'avec les
américains sur la question ukrainienne
bruxelles devra trouver des propositions
plus audacieuses pour s'imposer comme un
potentiel médiateur